thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another very special
episode of the careful boys where we are
currently off the Record and today we
are talking about times that we told our
women something to spare their feelings
so lie lie to them wow look at this
trouble bro yeah you're trying to get us
in trouble huh no I just think it's
interesting
you saying like a white lie or sparing
information I mean whatever you want it
to be right yeah like when she goes have
you ever cheated on you're like no but
you really do you want to go with that
one yeah that's a great one that's what
Joe said let's share those stories the
time like when you did it and you told
me about it
bar all right I'm gonna do spin the
knife spend the night two goals first
all right
and you can't deflect I gotta think of a
story dude that's the hard part no when
I lie because I lie so often
it's you it's you it's you it's you
it's me all right because you're bigger
so you got it you got your arms you have
more width
to be honest
I think this is actually my fault
oh where I don't and then I get in
trouble even worse for being too honest
you are kind of nervous because I have
Asperger's so when they say something
I'm just the bar you don't have asthma
Bart Burgers Bart Burger whatever they
ask me I really think I like listen to
the words and I go oh okay this is
exactly what I heard so I will give you
the response and then they'll let you
stupid [__] that was I was looking for
like you didn't listen to me emotionally
you listen to me logically and then
that's how you should get in trouble and
then you blame Asperger's which is
really smart that's all I said I say I
say I'm sorry that's right I have Bart's
Burgers dude but then the damage is done
though you know what I mean I came home
the other day and uh Tiff was watching
your ngo's podcast which one and it was
the one where it was like if you could
change anything about me like what would
it be and then your face was like he was
responding to the question and I I was
actually getting annoyed at Bart I was
like Barney you're such a [__]
[__] dude I've been down this road
before but she really wanted to know
yeah she goes what would you change
about me he goes your white hairs
and he was like and you have a bunch of
[__] cavities or whatever the [__] is
in there that's silly gross
his face was so straight I was like Dad
it hurt my feelings bro I was like damn
Bart what's your problem bro it looks
like you could try that [__] mind for
copper and that [__] I was like damn
it's not being so mean to Geo [__]
silver reminders like to slap a marble
you had in your old place
that looks like a [__] out of cavities
up there what the [__] do you do [__]
duplicate keys in your mouth or what
I'm not change about me well first off
you old hag those [__] hairs when I
watch that video I go man Bart really
can't lie about it he got some uh T-1000
in there hey babe they're not filling
the potholes every place in the city are
they oh my God that's the the one that
got me the most in trouble was uh oh man
I forgot how it even came up
but somehow I don't know what Ally ooped
I could tell you my dunk and I don't
even know why I dunk like that but I
told her when she was pregnant it didn't
turn me on
that's a massive great solicitors
[Laughter]
hey but then your score went up by two
yeah
baby I got evicted out of the NBA for
[__] two years
did you call her fat or some [__] I
could have there was something else I
could have I remember it was like it was
something like oh man you [__] gained
some weight oh I miss your old body or
something like that you wanted that [__]
maybe it was something like that
something like along the lines of um
Freaky Friday and it's like duh you got
pregnant that's why she was fast all the
guys think about I just say it and I get
in trouble so remember the problem was
like you don't say something to spare
them yeah but what there's such a thing
as sparing them you're the opposite I'm
the opposite so I [__] up just turn into
the room
yeah
I'll give you a good example okay of
that exact thing okay go you go so I had
an action I lived with for a very brief
time
um and what happened ultimately why we
broke up and why she left the apartment
and everything was because I caught her
emailing her ex like talking about when
she was gonna go visit him yeah and
that's ultimately why
that is not truly ultimately why
the real reason is that months before
she had dyed her hair this really ugly
color yeah and uh she wore this lipstick
that I thought was so gross I couldn't
stop thinking about it so she turned to
a different person and I had lost
so you must have felt like
yes when she was cheating on you no I I
already I it just happened to be
something worse and you found my excuse
huh yeah you made it her fault you son
of a [__]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
if something had turned you off and you
were just like oh God I'm still turned
off now and then coincidentally
something worse happened then it was
like oh well good I don't have to say
that now was that perfectly timed or it
was like a month or two it's like it's
like a month that's omitting but it's
not really the same example I think
Steve's example is more so like straight
up lied in a face she just got through a
[__] car accident she looks like a
monster and [__] but then you go you
know what baby you've never been more
beautiful oh I got a good one I've seen
it fixed your face baby you don't even
get it you don't need plastic surgery
anymore I have a good one I'm going this
is recent too this is recent this is
when we went to go to Hawaii and we saw
you in uh in in Waikiki yeah we were at
and my my lady was going through a foot
injury or her leg was like swole like
gross I know she gets it all the time
huh what [__] foot [__] no it's just
it's the same one
all the time yeah dude it's been the
same injury the doctors oh it's [__]
foot [__] again here we go the doctor's
just like oh great honestly that's how
they've been treating us for the most
part anyways we're at Waimea Bay and
she's like we're walking out and every
time she walks it swells up a little bit
more because
[__] girl get her some crutches fool
I did but she didn't want to use them
some Heelys get her a rollerblade just
one oh that's fine and then she could go
like this but she's much better now
anyways but good we're walking out and
she goes hey babe like does my leg look
swollen and I know Tiff is like she like
she spirals if I tell her the [__]
wrong thing and she'll like be like oh
my God she can't enjoy the [__] day
yeah yeah yeah when I was looking at her
leg and it was looking like not like a
leg I recognize you know elephant stumps
wow okay not elephants bro that's my
wife dude chill bro jeez did it look
like Uriah Faber after Jose Aldo it kind
of looks it looks swollen it was like
visibly swollen it looked like garlic no
it didn't because the gout is actually
like more in the toe actually but it was
so swollen like I looked at my sister
was it kankly no it was like up in like
like around the knee it was like
swimming around everybody just keep
asking questions before you can get to
it you guys understand what a swollen
leg looks like yeah it looks like a
toddler's leg Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah
Yeah Yeah
yeah but she was like babe they're like
does my leg look like swollen and I'm
like I look at like my sister-in-law and
she's like she's looking visibly worried
too and I'm like I'm like not baby like
totally fine [__] liar dude you look
[__]
primo and then I looked at my sister and
I was like we should get her to sit down
we gotta elevator foot like this is like
I'm we're actually getting kind of
worried a little bit but did it pay off
it was she like oh good I couldn't enjoy
yeah yeah yeah like she kind of stopped
thinking I would have had her feelings
hurt to be told her leg is swollen not
her feelings hurt but like but she's
like she would have been tripping she
was like a Perpetual like worry [__]
already had Tendencies to start tripping
so that's right [__]
[__] trip man yeah that word
hypochondriac that [__] is just women
so your story is my chick bumped her leg
and then like she got a bruise no yeah
babe it's good that's that's what you
got that's what I got well recently I'll
think of another one there's like way
more details than any other store yeah
that's why that's why I brought it
wasn't so Random limb yeah it looked
like a toddler's leg I say what limb
it was an Uncle's lip maybe you know
it's one day at Bay it's the actual name
of a beat that's true and then I can
cooperate because and he was visiting me
in Hawaii and she had a boot-ass leg
Yeah it was like wow yeah she showed
Hannah anybody have one that's maybe
four times crazier than that
I don't have anything great for my
girlfriend he's a smooth liar though you
didn't tell her her leg was swollen the
comparison straight it has to be from
guys who are considerate who understand
maybe this is not the right thing to say
who has who I've attacked who has
attacked but also who's good at lying
well when when have you done that [__]
dude I just go straight for the Hail
Mary's and and I don't know I either
[__] deny it completely and change
the subjects I don't even want to go
there or I just say straight up like bar
that's an example
an example Hail Mary you mean like [__]
it Chuck it yeah just go for it it's
just kind of like well I think like when
it comes to the uh if I know like the
physical stuff or like if they're
hypochondriac I don't want to make it
worse for them so at those times I'll be
like man you're [__] crazy and I tell
them to do the opposite thing you should
run a mile with that [__] boot on
your leg you know and then
later I'm like that maybe that was the
worst the best thing to say but [__]
we're gonna go I'm using his wife as an
example right now not like like
something you did I'm gonna try to run a
mile
nah you know what I'm really good at is
avoiding it all together when it gets
tense yeah I don't [__] answer it the
example I don't have nothing dude I do
that too though because when they try to
bring that [__] up and I'm like
[__] there's no way to answer this man
what was the situation that was brought
up and then how did you yeah Julie this
is six times he's like y'all [__]
Chuck a hell man what'd you have to do
no matter run away
what's the time you did it hey check it
out though this is what I think
tell us about it would you who'd you
hurt dude I'm like Bart I got no
examples
how about you guys keep talking it might
trigger a better memory usually that
does happen
this is the most recent thing that I
could actually think no I don't have
nothing smooth or crazy I didn't kick
somebody out of the apartment and break
up she was cheating dude I will say that
there's like for example I remember when
I brought Nina home to my parents
and then we would eat dinner and stuff
and then my mom would speak to me in
Vietnamese and in Vietnamese she goes
how come your wife's not cleaning up
oh and she said in Vietnamese yeah did
you say because she's a Filipino no
because at the end of the day I think
they do too oh no I know it should but
then I was like I don't I'm not gonna
say that that's like Wax so the only
thing I could do is get up and clean up
myself yeah you know what I mean because
I'm like how am I gonna translate that I
don't want to make my mom look bad
either yeah you know what I'm saying
that's a tough spot I didn't want to put
her that's a good example the way my mom
would ask something like that
she would she's waiting for the answer
because then she's already she already
put out oh you're the lady you brought
in is uncivilized
so if she doesn't civilize herself she's
not worthy of this family is how my mom
would like how do you that's tough cater
back I don't think my mom's that intense
on maybe like 50 so again I think it's
it's it was quicker for me to just get
up and clean up so the situation was
changed does that like make her go like
oh [__] like he doesn't if my if that so
if that was my mom in that situation
I would clean but I would be on my mom's
mind still she was like okay so she is
so unruly my son had to step in wow and
she still needs to be educated on this
like okay here's the point
like that and like here's like a [__]
the 30-point inspection on this car you
are not Car Max material
like that inline [__]
it's it's just it's a lose-lose
situation so the only thing that I feel
like I could do is just like change it
myself you know I mean change the
variables is all damn that's good and
your mom was like oh I forget but I just
saw keep going on a dinner time I'm sure
I probably clap back in some quickly
I'll be like I'm not gonna say that's
right now I'll just do it myself Nina
didn't understand what she said yes and
I wasn't gonna say that to Nina either
is that what you're saying I think the
second I got up and started doing things
she chose to get up and start doing oh
that's dope oh wow I'm still sitting
down enjoying myself for having the
conversation suddenly she's gonna start
getting up and cleaning up after every
good navigation dude what about when you
go home do you talk to her about it like
hey like my mom be tripping next time
you gotta I feel like what that's one of
those things that's also so slightly
small yeah that it doesn't do any good
to do anything and it also kind of
paints my mom and also a little bit of
like a really old school way that like I
don't care to pay my modeling so you
never told Nina about this hi see this
is what's beautiful about Anthony I
learned so much because I car crashed
both ways I'm like [__] why are you
talking about women like that hey Jill
can you [__] clean next time because
you're [__] a ruling
and this [__] car crashes both ways
it's all liabilities yeah everyone gets
it all right see Mom that's why I don't
bring [__] chicks over to eat with
you cause you say dumb [__] and I'm like
Geo you are a Savage you need to go
[__] quick
getting for himself to watch a drama
he's making his life work he never has
his own back I know mine has never gone
The Reflex of like oh I should spare
someone's feelings in this huh I try to
sometimes
try to somewhere but he's so bad I can't
hold it in lie I tried to oh my God
that's funny
because I feel like if I do then now I
gotta keep track of all the [__]
things I say it's yeah it's like keeping
track of the lies then it's so hard
because then next time it might you
might get caught slipping you're like oh
yeah oh yeah when you're pregnant you're
so fine you know they're pregnant again
I won't spare I don't miss your whole
body at all that's like an outfit or
fashion though oh like at home it's like
if it's like she's like how do I look
I'm like that doesn't match like what
are you thinking
what are you talking about what do you
think she'll do the same to me too right
I'll be like hey can I wear this do I
look good she'd be like
no no I'm changing you know what I mean
it's like it's very I did that when uh
with my ex when she had a dreams of
being a speed skater out of nowhere
because Apollo Ono got popular so she
was like I want to do that I think
that's what I want and she bought speed
skates over like hundreds of dollars and
went to her first class and I was there
to support her and I was like you need
to actually go [__] fast oh [__] I
was like because I was pissed because I
was like this is unrealistic you're
afraid to go fast you want to be a speed
skater
not more than any normal Charlie Brown
character oh [__] I was like actually
mad because she because she had this
thing like you don't support me why
don't you like believe in my dreams I'm
like you don't want to go fast yeah a
speed skater yeah that's hilarious like
I I think I earned that one how long
were you guys dating for after that two
two very bad deers oh wow but that was
along the second year so it was on its
way out yeah very slowly on the ice
that's a tough situation what about you
though
are you just a smooth criminal yeah so
yeah
he's asking for tips so for 10 years I
have been with Nikki
that's a long time and yeah and for 10
years I have been telling her that I
think Filipino food is like my second
favorite of all fine really and for 10
years I have been so full of [__]
[__] here
[Music]
[Laughter]
I think Filipino food is [__] trash
that's what I think
that's how you [__] fit that's how
you finish in a video dude just put it
in the in the trash where it belongs
it's pretty good I I was just I just
pretend to eat like that put the fork
down flip it upside down in the trash
and I just hear all that [__] two
pounds of food just go
I do that move right I do the same move
upside down plate moves means ew yeah
I can't imagine you not wanting to tell
her that I know right why would that be
something that you couldn't wait to tell
her that her old cultural food belongs
in the trash no
why would that be something to lie about
thankful thankfully JK fans are gonna be
cool they're not gonna Center this okay
don't blow up the Spy right yeah please
trying to keep this one going for
another 10 years
so we'll see damn dude
I couldn't think of one story where I
[__] lied to a girl
hey
hey some of us aren't perfect
I just [__] alienated half of my
family yeah that's true you're not gonna
do anything
Hail Mary's here you're not gonna
[__] Chuck it
but like Bart dude's crazy you you're
just so like
not really
I don't [__] up that hard I don't say
that kind of [__] but I do say stuff I
just don't remember
I'll figure it out in five other videos